hello people i'm jaby kawaii with me is
achara kirk we're gonna watch all of us
are dead episode four today if you want
the full length uncut reaction where you
sync up with the time code that will be
over at our patreon page if you can hit
the like button that would be very much
appreciated subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for all of us are dead
is up here on the channel thanks to the
boys at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights
let's have fun
it's a wonderful intro jabby
hi
doesn't sound that weird
foreign
actually that's pretty smart keep
livestreaming
yes
get the proof out
i wish i could read the live chat i know
look how they're super chatty
i hope this guy gets to see some of that
money
damn lady
so worried about you
no
[Music]
no
[Music]
what is that helicopter doing i
i don't know
it wasn't just can't they try to flag
down that helicopter
that's so messed up yeah i was really
hoping her dirty like that yeah
i was hoping she would make it at least
part way through this episode
[Music]
you guys can pee out the window can't
you yeah take turns you know the guys
can be out of the wood
you know just
dangle your
your bits outside
the helicopter people didn't notice them
on the roof come on
can't you poop out the window yeah just
to sit on the ledge
this is like the weirdest video game
instructions i've ever heard
tutorial
the rescuers come with poop as much as
we were
just start crapping right in our pants
and then every time you open the door
you'll get hit with noxious fumes
it's the bathroom episode
[Music]
by the time they're done with this
hour-long
foreign
oh is her mom the one who's at the
hospital with the firefighter oh maybe
yeah
we know her mom's got status
it's probably not as easy to fly down a
chopper as you move these off and make
it
they are really far away yeah and you
must look really tiny from up there
oh god this [ __ ]
serves you right
got him
please don't tell me he's gonna find his
way to the roof oh you gotta be [ __ ]
me here
oh
that is the best place to hide that is
the
jeez
[Laughter]
when is the safest time to move magic
hour
guys calm down you guys have the
bathroom
you know how lucky you are right now
[Laughter]
get those subs buddy
your watch time must be incredible
he's gonna have no more content after
this
nothing's gonna talk back to getting
attacked by zombies
way better
[Laughter]
i hope this guy makes it
damn it must have like some type of
external charger going now korean phones
are just light years ahead of us
comment below tell me where i should go
no
come on dude
the day he was born you're an idiot baby
is
[Music]
oh god i hope he [ __ ] dies i hate
that guy so much this show's gonna bring
him to the very end
oh
good debate
[Music]
there's anyone who could solve this
debate get him some equipment and a
specimen lock him in a lab
don't you want a gun man
bam john wicked
[Music]
well
accepting them for what you made them
though
[Music]
oh
there you go
[Applause]
go man who do it man you're not gonna
have another
chance wow what a death what a symbolic
way to die yeah
[Laughter]
savior of the anguished
oh man the whole thing went to [ __ ] out
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's nice things your legs still work
after being pinned behind a truck i
thought this cop was going to be like a
total dick and now i'm like
really counting on you damn man yeah
our only hope
it's a beautiful morning
[Laughter]
oh my god she better be the one to kill
him
wow
[Music]
come on come on
go
[Laughter]
you're a beautiful man
[Laughter]
[Music]
hopping now drop down
all you guys know parkour oh you guys
got strong arms
i mean she might not be dead but
nah she did
[Applause]
just hulk out and throw them all off
what i don't know
maybe she's the special
what
no way
oh my god it's still scheduled you'd
have to yeah you'd have to go into his
account
oh no she's turning i thought i thought
there were some like yeah that she had
some kind of auntie body or something
oh my god oh she messed it up
dammit
oh man dude whoa man
the [ __ ] you're responsible for so
much i hate you so much
yeah he's really gonna fall through with
it
i cannot tell what's happening
[Music]
[Laughter]
no please make it my dude man
don't let this happen
make the floor wet so they slip yeah
you mean bolt cutting isn't as easy as
it looks in every other movie
no
no come on oh i really want him to live
i know
why are you moving slowly
no
[Music]
do not night of the living dead him
why is someone charging in it i don't
know
they'll just
chill out
for a minute
oh my god no
no
damn
you straight up murdered him now turn
him back
[Music]
no
are you [ __ ] kidding me
he landed that
what is
he's an expertly trained knife thrower
oh god
yeah
that
[ __ ] egg
the amount of depth he's a second he
gets
the second episode already
out of four
is he about to die yeah yeah
oh no he'll be fine what a pain and
he'll charge that guy is god damn what a
d what a what a massive erect penis yeah
that was a gripping show though
i was really into that
holy crap
that was really great i was like man
this alley flies by it does it's so
intense and [ __ ] hell and a lot of
like i don't understand how this
person's living right now but okay
yeah what's the girl in the prince in
the teacher's office jeez i still can't
tell what's happening to her and the
choreographer the way they staged that
with the fire hydrant and the shots
outside of the stairwells that are
coming on that was wonderfully staged
yeah um that was that was intense that
was really intense all right let's uh
let's talk about it
i'm still waiting for the point in the
show when people are like it's gets slow
and boring
yeah i know every time i feel like we've
had that sort of preparation uh like
thrown at us or just put in mind
you know for almost every episode up
until this point and none of them have
felt anything less than like gripping
and immediate to me
yeah i don't know is it like those
little attention to details of
like when they they're trying to figure
out the bathroom situation because
because well the thing is i'm a
pretentious film snob
so i love those things i do too
i'm like yeah
i haven't seen a zombie flick where
everyone has to figure out where you
watch both the kids and the adults have
to figure out oh wait what about the
bathroom now that we've been here for a
day that's such a realistic thing
i like that i weirdly think that's a
really good detail to include in your
story and uh i i appreciate [ __ ] like
that i appreciate
the
[ __ ] appreciate piss like that
i like i like the details of of
a weird situation like that because when
you're isolated
i don't know have you guys ever tried
writing something you guys if you're
writing something a lot of times
especially if you care about like
realism of what characters might have to
deal with i i i that's something that
oftentimes like in a movie you're like
we don't have time for that let's just
move along nobody cares
a show
why not take some time to to have a
little bit of a awkward discussion about
what that is and yeah you know the
bathroom thing is
that's a huge it's very relatable yeah
that's a relatable and especially with
the kids who can be uncomfortable with
such a thing anybody you can be
uncomfortable with such a thing yeah
like it's it's a human vulnerability
that we all have to experience and they
get most all cultures or many cultures
have like a lot of you know finicky
things around so yeah having everybody
lumped into this room together it like i
don't know to me that's part of the fun
of
the science fiction of this is going
okay what is the true scenario of
survival and how do we encompass all the
aspects like because there's that and
then they go on talking about like you
know we're gonna run it we don't have
any food or water so you know we're
gonna be dehydrated by tomorrow and
we're gonna starve by the next day yeah
they're well-educated kids too so i like
seeing their the intellectual
discussions around it and then them
trying to understand
what someone else is really implying or
really talking about
i think though those those nuggets are
so vital i think to to making this stand
out
and uh even like the this is the most
like adult drama that i think we've
gotten of
you know like
it seemed like it was pretty equally
split or divided between going to the
hospital like
if you siphon it off between
uh guinom and the rest of the kids
like being the kids and then the other
storyline being the hospital and the cop
you know so it seemed like there was a
really equally divided story line
between uh kids and adults and what
they're dealing with
and uh what is the dad's name we have
him did we do not write his name down
here no oh no the father the creator of
yeah or a great zombie virus lee
something or other just call him creator
joe's dad
oh no
oh that guy okay yeah yeah the creator
the creator of the virus yeah sorry i
thought he was a firefighter dad
but yeah the firefighter that i'm so joe
is the firefighter
i wrote it down oh you did wow
we have ten characters so terrible yeah
um
well okay where to start with
i mean we'll find out what happens with
with these with some of the students
like uh oh we didn't write her name down
either we should have taken the time but
the girl who is the one with the who's
been videotaped
you know um that
i think one of the most p piece uh
biggest pieces of conversation to derive
from here is the one that is argued
between the cop and creator
and watching uh like discussing like the
the differences and how this all
progressed you know and like we've the
show covers so much about
the what the the the effect of being
bullied does and what that can
ignite and i like the moral debate of
what they had of like how do how is it
up to us to decide
when is it okay to take a life and
when's it not okay to take a life
or
how this show like like i said i'll
reiterate again for americans who don't
have much familiarity with how you know
societal norms are in like south korea
and stuff
however like at least the world that
this show presents
is
like the the way how with this hierarchy
goes societal systems and whatnot uh
systematic systems i mean and how that
all plays out like when he's when the
when the creator is talking about
um you know they everyone had a role to
play everyone was complicit to a certain
extent just based off of societal norms
that they would not stand up for such a
thing that it's just normal let's
justify the situation let's minimize the
situation let's downplay everything
and the fact that a lot of people are
kind of privy to a lot of the bullying
that goes on in a lot of the the
inhumane ways to treat people
so by proxy or just association just by
being witness and not doing something
they have a hand implant they play a
certain hand in it
and so i like like where they establish
where the creator dad was coming from
especially when it's your own son who is
the one who has to suffer the
consequences of what
is being passed along as normal and just
because it's normal doesn't mean it's
okay and then of course on the cops end
of things being like okay you said a few
things right
but that doesn't mean it's like you got
to kind of uh you know give punishment
based off of the way the crime is done
you can't just
automatically jump to murdering and what
this show is also doing
is
bringing it back to a more uh
archaic
biblical time in a way like there's so
much talk about humanity too and you
know bringing humans back to their more
animalistic roots to how we were
years ago and i think that's kind of why
like the bathroom thing is is a
fascinating thing to me because you know
we just finished kingdom and there was a
section in kingdom
where you know like back when the show
kingdom takes place another korean
zombie show
that's a much more historical time
period where i don't think this whole
thing about like where do we [ __ ] and
piss is gonna be as much of a discussion
because like there's they're they're
they are qualities
luxuries yeah they don't have toilets
that flusher or you know [ __ ] like that
that we rely on uh for comfortable
hygiene when going to the bathroom
so i so i like that this is like
stripping us back to the bare bone
minimums and then like the way he was
comparing it with
um like uh should uh about like
he was making like animalistic
comparisons oh yeah they're seeing eye
dog
should all should all dogs give up their
natural instinct to run and bark should
all people give up their natural
instincts too yes for civility's sake
yeah so if anything and he does die in
in this like that jesus-like pose that
they didn't like slow motion it down but
it did seem like a really symbolic way
for him to die as like the creator yeah
who dies they completely devoured every
inch yeah yeah so i think that this is a
i think it's fascinating the way they do
it and while they take their time out to
have these more philosophical
discussions about live society morals
humanity whatnot it's also uh just a
gripping intense series too i i think of
the the zombie [ __ ] is really gripping
to to
to watch and there's some deaths in here
that really kind of that bugged me a lot
like
um
uh chung sun's uh mom being killed at
the very top of this that sucked so much
he's so rooting for her the way some of
these people die is just so uh
it adds to the realism of it and
sometimes it is like it's it can be
frustrating it's stark in matter of fact
in a way it's funny because there are
certain things
where like you know the the main guy
yeah uh chung sun like he he escaped a
few scrapes in in more of a kind of
traditional narrative sense but yeah i i
like
that they are willing to really dial in
that bleakness when it comes to like
there are so many characters who get set
up with these motivations where you're
like well they can't die or we have to
see some kind of dramatic resolution and
you know part of i think the point of
some of those things is that yeah
especially i mean in life already and
then in an advanced accelerated
situation like this it's not gonna work
out like that and so i'm fascinated to
see what they're gonna do with the girl
who uh you know who's undergone the
with the tape who's undergone this
intense sort of assault and bullying
because it seems as though they're
hinting at some kind of thing where like
she's getting
taken over very slowly i can't tell if
they're going full zombie with her or
not but even that is like you want to
see her get some kind of retribution and
it appears as though she probably won't
and that's kind of
you know that's one of those sad twists
of the knife that you're like yeah you
know in the real world she probably
wouldn't get some kind of big uh
emotionally satisfying resolution out of
this and i liked even that debate of
them on the roof and and you know the
guy with her and the positions that
they're both thrust into because that
you know is obviously under the
microscope now of you know complicity
and assault
and you know seeing the two of them both
emotionally work that out and then come
to how their wills to live and why are
affected by this and these two people
who are so beaten down and her with
somewhat of you could argue with even
more reason you know to be feeling this
way than him you know her being the one
to be like no i'm going
i need to do something at least
you know
um yeah i i've seen a couple of those
comments too people saying you know like
i you know like there's a lot of cool
intense stuff but then it'll just like
take a break to explain the point um and
i i maybe we haven't come to those
moments yet but i feel like you know
there have been moments in this episode
that made me think of those comments but
i didn't really share that
opinion either that same thing about
slowing down or isolating the point i
feel like a lot of the debates they're
having are natural debates to be having
in the settings that they're put in
and being that this is such real time
being that we're only on the second day
like we just got through the first night
you know and uh yeah i feel like this
show is a great example of how to have
your cake and eat it too with a zombie
story because
by the end of this i would imagine you
know it's like you have all these
different characters between the adults
and the kids who are all standing in for
different
kind of issues or conflicts that exist
within society and then we're seeing the
kind of the overarching umbrella is how
like the the need
to adhere to a certain societal protocol
keeps us from getting to the actual
solution to things or to some kind of
actual healing or some kind of actual
progress
um so like it's i'm fascinated by how
they're using the characters and to see
where some of them will end up to
understand what the true point is
because there's a lot that does
when you have characters dying in such
abrupt and stark ways some things can
feel sort of random but i don't begrudge
at that necessarily because that's also
an aspect of life you know well i think
this the the theme of this particular
episode
was about
um
the value of life and what is the value
that we place on life
that seemed to be what it all even even
down to the girl when she was brought
with the the question of
why
why kill yourself
when that that video is already going to
be out there yeah like is is it worth it
what can you really escape people
already see it
and
that seemed to be like the biggest stem
for when you look at like everything
that you were watching here of
how and then even with the firefighter
and the politician lady um how they were
talking about
he wants to go save his daughter but she
was saying like we have to we can't just
save those that are most precious to us
we have to
we have the most we have to save the
most we can
and so again it goes back to
value in life and it's a really i think
it's a really interesting debate that
they have
per episode with the through line of
of um inhumane treatment and that this
how the zombie virus in a lot of ways is
representative of who we are underneath
at all yeah which i've heard brought up
in in zombie properties before that this
is merely an amplification of the human
nature uh at the same time though it is
it's done in a more
uh
visceral way where they keep the action
alive still
where some stuff doesn't like you
sometimes gets brought into question
with its rules like the guy who was
trapped behind the car i'm like this guy
would have been dead
yeah yeah
how's this guy's like hey how's he
moving is he walking yeah and how did he
not just get devoured on the other side
yeah yeah yeah unless they mistook it
but i do think that girl
i don't know i think i wonder if that
was just some mislead of her like
slightly twitching
yeah because they did start chewing on
her
and
then then they left her yeah they they
just they markedly stopped yeah and
we're like uh
we're gonna go someplace maybe she's
dead on the inside
and it's some kind of metaphorical magic
i don't know but yeah like that that of
all the threads that's the one where i'm
like she's the special somehow
maybe they're gonna do something where
like the bullied kids all have some
special gene
if you've been victimized
to the extreme yeah you are immune to
the virus
which is not true i mean we've seen some
people could not because i mean the
first kid would never have turned yeah
yeah it would never have worked
but yeah
this is a fascinating this is really
well done and even with the politic even
with the the woman
like i i thought they did nicely coming
out of the previous episode to make even
the people in the office feel a little
more
nuan like they didn't just cling to that
one beat of like it's she's the
councilwoman what are you doing she's
the most important person why aren't you
catering to her at all like they kind of
left and progressed a little beyond like
they're still aspects of you know those
protocol like the principles like you
know you're expelled
uh for doing this which is like i don't
know you know those don't apply anymore
uh so like those aspects still persist
in certain pockets but i feel like the
way they're advancing even those things
with those characters who initially
present themselves is ah you're going to
be frustrating you know they're good at
wearing those edges down
and uh now all that i'm gonna wait and
see is if they're able to do that to uh
to uh what's her name not young
because uh you know i imagine in the
next episode chung's son has to come
across her and miss park at some point
now they're out they're all split up and
stuff maybe they can help him get rid of
guinom or something
it seems like the worst people tend to
survive this situation yeah or hey i
mean maybe maybe
guinom will run into the girl and she'll
just eat it maybe they're holding her
transformation until the just the right
moment uh that's
kind of what i'm hoping for but now
there's something a little too thematic
about what happened there yeah
all right we'll see anyway it's good i
i'm really enjoying it and i i'm yet to
be bored nah the only time i thought the
rhythm was off was the first episode
yeah yeah i can't wait to watch the next
one each time we finish what like it's
funny because yeah they are so
substantial and i've said this each time
they're each like a movie but yeah they
fly by
yeah and i think the way they captured
the zombie action is choreographed so
well too oh yeah just like so compo like
it's so visceral and mean
and the actors are so
committed to that but also it's so
composed and so thought out like it's
it's mightily impressive what they're
able to do here
oh god
i don't know what's going on with the
helicopters
i don't either i mean i i i just like i
guess they don't have that many
resources and uh
yeah are they just rescuing people
slowly
i know that you never see them drop down
like unless i got a flare don't go down
there yeah yeah
i mean because yeah we see that that big
line of them from the kids perspective
and i'm like yeah what's are they just
hovering there what's going on
or are they just tending to again yeah
like people in the city
positions of government or something
maybe i mean helicopter can drop down on
a school roof can't they yeah it doesn't
seem like it would be that hard
they just need a flare that's all they
need they got to go to the they've got
our influence for god too yeah
oh
yeah that's right i hope he makes it i
like that a lot
i love seeing his little live stream
comments we got a couple translations of
those
in the subtitles yeah
i don't know it also seems like it does
this thing about
like a lot of this seems to be some
weird commentary on status too yeah
status and the ways that it pollutes our
ability to just see a situation for what
it is and do the right thing yeah you
know it's even like the influencer thing
while funny also has a commentary to it
yeah
of like like and subscribe yeah like
like it's funny but i also think there's
some deeper thing to it because
um what was the point i just said [ __ ]
so i thought i forgot what i said uh it
having this thing about his statuses
yeah and authority oh yeah it's like
this is this is oh yeah it comes back to
like stripping people down to
we've created these
more like we've we assign as humans as
we
age on in this planet we
assign what is
right and wrong like there are things
that we consider wrong now that a
hundred years ago
would have been totally cool you know
and
this is just keep stripping that back
even more and then people still try to
use status in a position to of applying
what's who's more important
when like none of that matters anymore
like threatening your bully character
with i'm going to expel you i'm like
that shouldn't matter right now
what do you think what leverage do you
think you have yeah i know that i know
in the moment though but i think that's
what this does well
is
a lot of the times you can read more
into things because
another version of that is that the
principal's just desperate to manipulate
the student to get in the car yeah you
know that's mainly what it what it reads
as but there's also when you look at the
other conversations that sort of
circulate around this series i think
that
also factors in even right down to the
creator guy like he was he felt pushed
into this position to try to come up
with something
because no one was standing up for
the
the
the plight of whatever his what his son
was dealing with at the time
so yeah let it all burn
let it all burn yeah i mean i felt i
felt for him i was like this isn't the
solution but also i got you yeah yeah
they did a good job i got you man all
right guys well keep a lookout for our
next reaction uh thanks for being here
and hey let's do a p
lance door you're the easiest one to
shout out for this why because we have a
character in this episode who is a
badass firefighter helped save the day
oh yeah and objectively speaking there
is only one firefighter at our patreon
page and that's you so guess what when
the zombie apocalypse rolls around we're
gonna need an asian firefighter on our
side yes and you fit both of those
descriptors man
lance i'm happy to have you on our
patreon page and speaking of status we'd
be the most important people you'd have
to protect yes your kid's not gonna make
it in the apocalypse all right there's
no point in even trying what are you
gonna try to repopulate no don't forget
the kid all right forget the wife
they're holding you back in life we're
going to be the ones you're going to
need to protect so lance
i appreciate your loyalty because
loyalty is important
especially in the apocalypse fidelity
that counts for something man
i use that word right yeah
faith fidelity yeah as we're talking
about yeah fidelity to us to to you know
your bros
well you know i mean we uh we went
through the whole thing about like you
know you can't have that fidelity for
like you know wife and kid because
they're just gonna weigh you down in the
apartment oh i don't believe in that
[ __ ] no okay
you could always replace those
[Music]